i
leave here and i go to town and then when i go
up again well
i like towns it
's like a strike if they lock him in a
cage he gets desperate and he gets
here you're alive wherever you
walk they see us  someone who doesn't bother you
and if you go down the street, well, a car around
here in storms running from
one to the government also leaves me
from the shepherd in what there was before,
especially the grazing, the grazing to
walk at risk because this here they go
Now the goats will be out of the sea and
to go faster,
simply cut the path because
there are paths, but to cut the path because
the bicharraco is coming, dance as
quickly as possible.
I learned it when I was little because,
as I saw my father,  Well, I was
curious, I always grabbed it,
nodding, lashing it, because
today they are used as a sport, but
before it was an obligation,
then you to dust in the place and let's
there uniform servers lift extension and they
sadden continuously ind  former family and
practices of constant traditions
churchill & lee jin song jang and to
serve is to fit pastor's jump when they
see daniel takes many times
and goes from my house to the village bar to
have a coffee and that I wanted to be a good
jumper so I used this
tool to make five or ten
minutes of walking and I took advantage of all
the small jumps that I found along
the way
my friends told me why they
didn't do it and that it was from old people
that it wasn't usual then when I
started showing photos of the places
where  had been able to arrive with this
tool and it changed their point of
view the shepherd's jump is a
practice that is why it has been
studied so far it appears that
the will is unique in the world where it is
practiced in the Canary Islands as in
a  super nice legacy that
our ancestors have left us and even to
walk the cliff
you saw us before going down for a
rich job but there are areas where
there are steps  It doesn't mean that there is
a path, but on the vertical wall,
no, you can't see it from the outside and it
seems impossible to get there, but when
you get inside you see there is a death in
mind, a few who list
what they call what we call  the
other steps and that's where they went
down because since the time of the
Guanches then it's a
wonderful thing I don't know how to go there and
maintain all that legacy that is there
my mind
will we wish we never be like the chief
of southern de  this one that he was the one who
introduced me to 4 panko with the best I did the
course of the month a spear and thanks to him he
began to know this great world
that highlighted all the areas that
allow you to know a tool like
dance
i